يراقب ايهم الجدار الحدوديه مع تركيا
ويتذكر الطريق المحفوفه بالمخاطر الذي
سلكه مع اطفاله في رحله الوصول الى اهله
في المانيا التي انتهت هنا حيث بدات وتمثل
الحدود السوريه التركيه نقطه الانطلاق
الاولى للسوريين الراغبين في اللجوء الى
اوروبا بمختلف الطرق البريه والبحريه
تاجرت الشمال السوري وحاولت اطلاع كتير
على تركيا طبعا طرق غير شرعيه لانه
الطريقه الشرعيه مستحيله هم في هيك شيء
بحكم انه ما الي حدا
بالشمال اهلي كلهم مغتربين برات البلد
حاولت كتير انه احسن نوصل لعندهم ما قدرت
يتحدث ايهم مع ابيه بحرقه ينقل له شعوره
بالياس من الوصول اليه خصوصا مع ازدياد
المخاطر عليه وعلى اطفاله خلال هذه الرحله
التي جربها مرات عده من مناطق عده ولكن
دون جدوى لقيت الشغله خطره اولادي اكثر ما
تكون خطر علي يعني واحده من المرات مهرب
بده يعني شرب اولادي منوم وانا ما قبلت
خليته يرجعني كنت على الحدود وقتها صارت
مشكله يعني سمع اصواتنا التركي كثر ما
عيطنا انا واياه وهيك مره من المرات بتذكر
كان في انا سمعان صوت الضبع قدامي
وخنازير بريه يعني مره من المرات هاي
المحاوله كانت من طرف عزاز تقريبا رغم
التشديده الامني من قبل الجيش التركي الا
ان هذا الجدار الحدوديه الممتده على طول
الحدود السوريه التركيه
يمثل نقطه الانطلاق الاولى
لطالبي اللجوء من السوريين تشهد الحدود
السوريه التركيه محاولات عبور غير قانونيه
بشكل يومي نحو الاراضي التركيه من قبل
شبان يبحثون عن اللجوء في مختلف الدول
الاوروبيه
ومنهم من يريد البقاء في تركيا بحثا عن
حياه اكثر استقرارا محمد الاشقر العربيه
الحدود السوريه التركيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات